c'est qu'on va partir en laponie en part
en laponie toute l'équipe honda à la
rochelle web à la recherche du père noël
va faire moins 27 je vous le dis tout de
suite il va y avoir des retards et voilà
tu en train de parler est en train de
finir à la bombe et je connais des
clercs partiront laponie il va falloir
gagner des jeux et aujourd'hui il y aura
des jeux voilà qui compteront et on aura
des points pour partir en laponie dès
aujourd'hui c'est une qualification
directe qui se joue pour la la attention
vous ne serez que 7 à partir en laponie
alors je vous le dis je ne fais pas des
sélections je vais vous dire pourquoi
parce que je suis obligé de partir mais
je sais pas quel jour je sais pas quand
il y aura des surprises
jennifer bien côté de moi jennifer
attention c'est très simple vous allez
faire le tour des cadeaux faits à courir
il y à des hôtes derrière le père noël
va vous verser quelque chose sur la tête
l'agresseur si vous avez la poudre d'or
ça veut dire que vous partez en laponie
jean gilles verdez attention si c'est de
la poudre d'or nous a qualifiés pour la
laponie ses partitions
[Rires]
les
c'est très simple on va reculer la
combelle à chaque fois celui qui
arrivera le plus loin sachez le sera
qualifié pour la laponie d'accord alors
on va vite là normalement aller au
sabbat bah ouais ça va merci là ça va
vite
ouais merci menottes à de nombreux merci
merci à isabelle parsy là bas aussi
merci attention c'est très simple vous
avez tout jouasse h et vous chers
téléspectateurs http laponie pour venir
avec nous puisqu'on aura une vingtaine
de présélectionner il y en a deux qui
partiront avec nous pendant tout le
séjour qui feront tout avec nous la
corniche chéri attention c'est parti
kelly winn y va avec vous je le fais ça
vous faites ce que vous voulez a caché
allez c'est parti on va vite aller alors
elle va vite
celui qui fera tomber la tour sera
éliminé définitivement de la laponie
père noël m'a dit attention un effet ce
nom
[Applaudissements]
serdar du couscous ça se fait qu'on se
calme montiel tout échéant tout le monde
monte moro is as tu vas te gâté là bas
mais je suis je ne suis pas qualifié
pour le monde je ne viens pas vous
regardent soit disant je tenais quoi
allécher les sols et l'eau reste plus
que 3 6 loups qui va gagner
alors à quand jusque là trop perdre que
dalle vous pouvez mettre d'eux-mêmes de
derrière pas mal aussi
allez dire à jean malié géraldine l aie
aie a été que j'ai eu très peur vix
ronnie ash voilà à les attentions
raymond h café devient dur là celui qui
fait tomber la tour sera définitivement
et je dis bien définitivement gelée de
la plainte est celui qui fait tomber la
tour ne verra jamais plus et je dis bien
jamais plus la neige les crs boris est
ce que tu peux nous faire une petite
démonstration on vous montrer que c'est
hyper simple dames à avancer bourriche
jamboree soit tu sais si tu le fais
souvent mais c'est la première fois que
tu le veuilles ou non ça fait plusieurs
années j'avais attrapé ou d'accord mais
on va dire que c'est la première fois
que je fais on va la refaire
bon il s'apprend la voie que tu le fais
oui c'est le bonheur vadim aux bons
risques
allez c'est parti boris contre nogaro tu
fais quasiment boris regardez c'est très
simple il va aller chercher le billet
vous connaissez voilà il ya une échelle
voilà voilà voilà beau mais c'est pour
vous montrer que c'est assez simple
voilà normalement il n'y a pas de souci
voilà à les remercier
personne
les cherry et on va jouer donc on dans
de l'hiver et vous allez venir chacun
votre tour appuyé sur une dent là dedans
qui fera fermer le crocodile en
qualifiera 1
enfin on dit ce qu'il a sur
disqualifiera et donc après le reste
aura trois je voulais lit et y en aura
un qui serait éliminé dit ça quand elles
sont fraîches les dons je peux pas
embarquer pour une sortie
[Applaudissements]
tu vois c'est bon t'es tu les cherry
dans un instant je prendrai une décision
[Rires]
je ne crois pas du tout dans un instant
j'ai prendre une décision vous la dirai
continuer à tester la ville a perdu jean
michel maire est éliminé attention c'est
pas alors attention attention sa
carrière deleasa s'accroche self est
halal est choqué on y va chauffer allégé
attention c'est jules rate c'est bernard
montiel qui gagnera son billet pour la
peau ni d'ailleurs je donne syrie liban
merci il a droit de le toucher
merci la loi dit mort il mort oui je
sais on me l'a dit ça allait alléger
allez gillou
[Applaudissements]
attention attention réfléchissez bien
comment pouvez vous avez dedans de soi
que ces 36 dont 26 dans la combine dans
32 30 2,36 et l'alphabet ses 26 la crise
il est d'une famille où la cid en plus
de la famille sans blague et ça
franchement ça me fait beaucoup de peine
que notre veut dire qu'on est vrai et
moi donc manquer dans la neige je sais
c'est pas vrai laura dans la tension
benjamin castaldi
je vous rappelle que si vous voyez de la
poudre d'or chez vous benjamin castaldi
si vous avez misé sur lui
http laponie gagnerait des points sinon
les deux races qui sont vos boîtes
restait sur une boîte parce que je vais
faire couler après puisqu'il y en aura
un des deux qui aura la poudre d'or
entre kelly et mathieu mathieu
mettez-vous la wii mais je fais que ça
me
si c'est pas là ça sera un des deux
attention benjamin castaldi
vous avez toujours eu de la chance au
jeu toujours toujours là tout attention
5 4 3 2
[Applaudissements]
bravo benjamin castaldi premier qualifié
pour la primaube à nungesser